the Khan Academy is most known for
what's now about a thousand videos on
YouTube it starts literally at one plus
one equals two and it goes all the way
up to college level calculus and physics
everything is in these very short
encapsulated videos one concept at a
time my cousin Nadia was visiting me
from New Orleans when I was in Boston
and she was having trouble with math she
was in 6th grade at the time I agreed to
do this remote tutoring with her so I
started putting up videos on YouTube and
before I knew at random people all over
the world started watching them and
cutting letters and testimonials and I
start getting excited about it and I
just kept going I think I've learned
really about math in the past three
weeks than I had in all four years of my
high school study and you watch them
just comprehend everything just use it I
ended up passing a whole bunch of tests
from this video one thing that kind of
shocked me I get a lot of letters from
the Middle East I get a lot of letters
from Latin America in Theo Pia ganda
it's really reached far more students
than I could have ever imagined right
now there are about a thousand videos I
started recording about three years ago
now I'm doing it full-time I'm hoping to
be able to put out a couple hundred
videos a year I see a world where
literally anyone with access to a
computer in the internet will be able to
go to the Khan Academy and get a
world-class education will be the
world's free Virtual School
you
you